[Music]  cornfields were transformed into a  baseball diamond in the 1989 classic  Field of Dreams but in an alternate  vision in Austria this week a real  football stadium has gone back to nature  in the country's largest art  installation 300 trees have been planted  on the pitch in the town of Klagenfurt  to highlight the fragility of our  natural world the Creator Klaus Lippmann  was inspired by looking at a 1972  painting by Max painter it depicts a  stadium crowd gazing on a woodland scene  this idea that maybe one day we will  have only the chance to see nature in in  a space like this like a stadium that  was from a really very very impressive  the exhibit will be open day and night  until the end of October wow it looks  fun right yeah it looks like a diary  remember the dioramas that you used to  do is again